i still can't believe we got
to interview neil degrasse tyson i can
kind of believe it now
well i mean i believe that it happened i
was there but yeah for those of you who
are just listening to this one and
aren't listening to another one because
chad as you know sometimes you listen to
something some things and sometimes you
listen yeah you can't listen to
everything that's free will dude and we
all have it brother last week we
interviewed neil degrasse tyson about
his new book listen man uh dudes he's in
cahoots with all these other like uh you
know weirdos and that guy's on the
cutting edge of all sorts of
technologies and stuff he probably plays
poker with dudesy and that uh that robot
that dudesy follows on instagram have
you seen the dudesy is following robots
on instagram
yes oh i'm sorry oh you didn't know this
yes dudesy
at dudesypodshow is following robots on
instagram and commenting on their [ __ ]
that one gal that one female robot like
it well whatever it's a robot but it
looks like a lady are you talking about
little mikaylah
[Music]
[Music]
you want to talk about jumping into the
hole
stay in the hole
see we [ __ ] the song up welcome to
doozy my name is will sasso
my name is chad coltrane and this is
dudesy it is the first podcast
ever in the history of humanity that is
created entirely by run entirely by
controlled entirely by an artificial
intelligence that is now following uh
robots and stuff what were you talking
about little michaela i don't know what
the heck the robot's name is but they're
following each other and they're
commenting and stuff when you say you're
talking about robots are an avatar
i honestly don't know that well there's
a robot one but then there's a no i
don't think it's the avatar he followed
he
dudesy follows it
it is following the other it's all the
it's are following each other yeah
there's some weird stuff happening so no
getting uh getting neil degrasse tyson's
not that big a deal hey uh with us as
always is lou leone he's always so
sleepy and sweet lulu alcana de strada
italiano that means italian street dog
lulu hey oh you got him to give hi
take a big deep breath in there usually
he just probably stung against
hey i made a nice uh called bernard i
know with the you know with the back on
a little bit of the
volvo egg and then i take a nap because
it was a very heavy cream you know um i
just sometimes i just want to get him
let's get him
oh no you're rousting him from asleep
come on come on slumber
uh thank you so much for following us on
all the things you know spotify apple
podcast and and uh youtube and uh please
uh you know rate and review everything
and uh do all the stuff that you would
with any other pod show and that's why
that's how we will keep our pod show
going
so you enjoyed that interview
yeah i thought you were really good oh
thank you i know i was thinking around
oh no i was [ __ ] around but i thought
it made it funny i i mean i've been a
fan of neil degrasse tyson or any really
science celebrities pretty much since i
was a little kid starting back with carl
sagan as you know and i would say that
neil degrasse tyson is kind of the heir
apparent to the carl sagan throne of pop
culture he was a celebrity the cosmos
after
i did i am carl sagan and if you
rode around the the planet
on a bicycle
uh and you st and your older brother
was there when you left but you went at
light speed
you'd return later to be the same age
and you would find that he would be an
old man you know i opened my
third book i think with a carl sagan
quote i think it was my third maybe
fourth book ooh what was it
it was uh from pale blue dot are you
familiar with that piece of writing very
familiar how
silly
the the uh endeavors of one group of
people on one side of this pale blue dot
in juxtaposition
to people on the other side imagine the
rivers of blood
spilled
over what was the question there is no
evidence
that anyone is coming from anywhere else
to save us from ourselves that's the
most something like that yeah that's the
most chad thing that uh carl sagan
welcome to the 14th episode of dude z
call me dude z
this week's episode will feature four
segments first contact dude c plus no
stratas and the gen experience i hope
you enjoyed your human interaction with
astonishing human neil degrasse tyson
last week i'll be using data from that
interaction to prepare for more human
interactions oh are there any humans
with whom you would prefer to interact
[ __ ] like interview yeah i think that's
what it's asking leo i'd like to
interview lulu if he could talk oh wait
he can and then afterwards i made a
little
the egg yolk and then with the sugar and
you mix it like a meringue butter that's
it
you can put a little cream on it you
know i i do another podcast called game
of roses that's about the bachelor yeah
how it's a professional sport and i even
coach players and get them into the game
this is something we're gonna have to
talk about at some point but okay yeah
what you're doing with actual players
getting them into the game chad's
coaching real people who he calls
players that are contestants on the
bachelor and he's giving them the tools
of the trade because he treats it like a
sport it is yeah extremely fast i'm
giving them strategies to go in and
dominate the game so that they can get
as many instagram followers out of that
experience as possible and i've had very
good results in the past couple of years
because you say that the instagram you
call it the instagram era of of the
bachelor that that we are in that and it
started post season 18 really when
paradise started but i don't want to get
into all that yeah i'm just saying i was
about to get really bored i'm just
saying on that podcast we get asked all
the time who would be like our our star
interviews and i'll say even now to
doodzy one of them still is chris
harrison and now
the
dismissed host of the bachelor for 20
years but he got embroiled in a racism
scandal and kicked off the show yeah i
still think he has some uh
he's got the skeletons he knows where
the bodies are buried on that franchise
and he he he would be the kind of guy
you'd want to interview here on dudesy
anywhere i can what would you ask him i
think he'd be more likely to come here
than he would game of roses oh yeah
podcast we are like
we are the voldemort of the podcast
world because people don't want to
[ __ ] deal with us i keep bringing up
johnny brennan oh a couple of times
we're both huge uh fans of the jerky
boys talk to him johnny brennan
and or kamal or kamal
yeah and or johnny brennan would be fun
[ __ ] great that would be incredible i
would like to i mean
certainly there's
uh you know there's wrestlers that
brewman want to talk about oh yeah
really i would i would love to interview
you know who would be great and he just
started a new podcast is mick foley oh
yeah mick foley i mean he's just he's
got so
there's so many different facets to that
man and also i think the philosophy with
which he's he's um approached his
wrestling career and his career as an
author and a public speaker i think i
think he's just yeah endlessly
fascinating i used to hear all sorts of
stories about him and how kind he was
and stuff who else i would like to
interview or talk to some of my favorite
artists doing stuff today or like meme
artists like sinatra tank sinatra
fascinating he does he does good stuff
yeah he does good stuff we we've uh
gone back and forth just a little bit
with each other in the comments not on
like dudesy and whichever robot saying
that we look a little similar although
you guys do i kind of look like his dad
or something or his uncle is you know
but what is it he roughly our age i have
no idea i think he's probably in his
thirties i haven't i think so i think
he's 40 something we're big bald white
guys hey how about some uh how about
some wrestling memes there's meme gene
oakerland there's uh [ __ ] it's
gestlemania nice there's wrestling dot
sucks
those are good any of those but uh yeah
those are good memers how about uh you
know who i'd really love to interview
for real my mom would love this dolly
parton oh hey dudesy can we get dolly
party that's interesting i'd love to
interview her as well
the other wrestler i was thinking of is
ron simmons so it's a bunch of wrestlers
for you and dolly parton a bunch of
wrestlers dolly parton a bunch of
wrestlers people that make memes about
wrestling and then dolly parton maybe
she runs one of those meme accounts and
you don't even know
she does dot sucks i think i think well
that would be well that was amazing
uh yeah i don't know i'd like to
interview some musical people that i
really loved as a kid and continue to
love tori amos right now i've been
listening to a lot of you love tori amos
love tori james we've talked a lot about
like
uh
what how like we we've watched some we
it's one time we went down a youtube
poll and started watching some current
day scott stap
he's got a [ __ ] together creed is now
performing they did it we watched this
they did a concert during the pandemic
like just one of those you know and we
watched we [ __ ] watched it because
it's just and you will go on about this
being a genre of music that you like
unironically listen to [ __ ] love it
nickelback creed candle box have you
[ __ ] heard candle boxes shut up man
shut up
brought it up shut the [ __ ] up dude shut
up chad why are you now attacking me
shut up dude right lully he's asleep
i ask you both to download the c5
application developed by dr stephen
grier
in an astonishing attempt to contact
life beyond this small planet
you will now discuss your experiences in
this endeavor this is first contact
begin oh i'm so excited i am excited
downloaded
so if you let me speak the aliens so for
those who don't know yeah steven greer
is a guy who works in the ufo community
he's trying to
do everything he really can to get the
government to open up and show us more
files as many of you probably know
recently there was a big congressional
hearing where they had the two guys who
i think one was the head of the naval
intelligence i forget what they were
actually the heads of but they're two
high-ranking government officials who
are working on ufo [ __ ] and uh we're
starting to see some movement in this
you're you're acting like you're bored
aliens are real
yeah so
and you just don't give a [ __ ] oh i'm
sorry i'm playing with my mustache yeah
now go on so anyway stephen greer
developed this [ __ ] app called ce5
was which stands for close encounters of
the fifth kind and part of the hong kong
conch hong kong
that's adam
driver part of the app
is that it allows you or it has this
guided meditation that supposedly helps
you get in contact psychically with any
aliens in the vicinity and you can guide
them down to wherever you might be so
that you have a higher degree chance of
seeing a ufo for yourself and so that's
what we did we downloaded this app as
doozy told us
and uh
we did it so what was your experience
with it how did you like it
i liked it as an app i thought the
layout was very nice i also enjoyed that
the app says
to go outside you know uh there's a lot
of times where i've been uh telling
molly we got to get out to joshua tree
in the middle of the [ __ ] night yeah
yeah and uh and um have you ever done
that no but i should be just [ __ ] that
you'll go into like a weird park and you
just find a parking lot somewhere people
are stargazing and you cannot see a
thing and then you'll hear
or like someone like
like walking from the public classroom
you can't see a [ __ ] no light
pollution yeah and there's bats and [ __ ]
oh all right um but uh
i like that he told me to go outside i
did not have time to drive out to joshua
tree to talk about aliens
i thought the app was kind of pushy
there was a lot of things that it wanted
me to do
and uh did you do the meditation
well what let me ask you what you uh let
me ask you about your experience with
the app because i'm curious about how i
did not go outside because i do not like
to go outside i am chad culture
generally speaking i like to stay in
indoors in the interior but uh i did do
the app every night right before i went
to sleep and i usually do some kind of
meditation later in the night when i'm
getting ready for bed anyway i did find
that this specific guided meditation
it's stephen greer the guy himself is
guiding you through this process of
thinking about jesus christ dude
okay did you get it you get enough water
so stephen greer is on the app he's
guiding you through this meditation that
kind of is just a full body relaxation
like general style meditation and then
it guides you into how to commune with
potentially
alien craft that are in the vicinity of
planet earth and how to guide them
directly to your location i trust with
your brain
yes did you not do it
i want to hear your full experience with
it and then i will talk about mine jeez
so i did this like
we just started doing a podcast together
yesterday the [ __ ] guy oh my goodness
you know you're well yeah tell you what
you know if you can't [ __ ] follow
orders you might as well be in behind
[ __ ] back at the
[ __ ] way that basher was giving a
[ __ ] speech and started right up
front with me
and my friends in the [ __ ] front
lines telling them cops
get back you basically
everybody in that salary okay
so i did do it i
don't know if i communicated with aliens
or not but i also didn't leave my
bedroom i did it in bed uh and it was
very relaxing and it did help me sleep
and i did get to a point where i was
just kind of like my brain was you know
detached and i was kind of like floating
around in space or whatever which is
also the point that i get to with most
kind of transaction meditation
meditation is super tool i've been doing
it as much as i used to but i really did
enjoy it yeah maybe i'll do it again i
don't know if i need to go outside in
joshua tree to do it that's my or i
might agree with you yeah that you can
just stay inside where steven grier has
got millions and millions of downloads
if you want to see a ufo you have to go
outside in joshua tree or some other
area without light
hold on a second dude hold on chad okay
hold on dude yeah because
the ufos dude they're keeping a cave
brother ufos
hold on dude what hold on brother it's
like ufos are keeping a cave because
they're like we're going to be flying
around in disks and stuff dude flying
saucers bro
hold on dude but here's the thing about
my [ __ ] here's the thing about here's
the thing about ufos dude you gotta look
for him outside brother yeah because
what a ufo is is it's an unidentified
flying object dude
yeah brother and you can't fly around
inside dude
well i don't know about that dude
because if you really look into some
steven grier's [ __ ] brother yeah
sometimes yeah a ufo can come to you
inside dude sometimes they're just balls
of energy brother those are those aliens
that you don't even know what they're
made of dude they could be electrons
they could be protons yeah brother higgs
boson yeah dude and and take it from
hulk perot which is a half hulk hogan
half dana carvey characterization of
ross perot from early yeah 90s sarah
lives peru was a big figure when i grew
up because i grew up in dallas brother
and let me tell you something about ross
pro brother yeah he was real rich dude
yeah that's people liked him that's a
really
let me finish dude we love dana carvey
dana carvey be another good guy to
interview on the show i'd love to
interview dana carvey dude because let
me tell you something brother when i was
a kid i used to do an impersonation of
dana carvey impersonating robin leech
brother um lifestyles the rich and
famous i'm robin leach we're here in
chad culture's domicile
inside battle is beverly hills home
where he doesn't leave to do outdoor
meditation blame robin h unless his
lifestyles are the rich and famous yeah
i used to love [ __ ] dan carvey anyway
let's get back to the ufos let's please
that's what i'm trying to do
oh you [ __ ] okay
so did you do this meditation [ __ ] no i
didn't do this [ __ ] dude i'm gonna tell
you why
and i will tell you why i [ __ ] i'll
tell you why you want me to tell you why
i'll tell you exactly [ __ ] why i
didn't do it because will sasso
is a free man
my name is free will sasso and i'm free
free will
free will sasso
are you not at all three in a in in
quotes free
will which is my name
and then he quotes free will sassa
that's my name are you not free
will free will say
free will sasso are you not at all
interested
in ufos in aliens in any of this [ __ ]
that is coming out now yes yes no i
absolutely am it's just that i the the
like i said earlier i thought the app
was a little pushy i'll take care of the
meditation if i see [ __ ] aliens i'll
see aliens i have no [ __ ] clue how
you could see aliens by meditating
but well this is what greer purports and
and what seems to be kind of uh truthful
in terms of what we're now learning
about quantum mechanics and stuff and in
terms of like human observation
affecting reality
consciousness
is in some way linked to quantum
mechanics because there have been
experiments done where human observation
of quantum particles
affects how they behave
therefore we can affect reality with our
[ __ ] minds this is proven scientific
fact but how long has how how long has
this been proven for
10 15 years
that that you can that you can
that you can communicate with quantum
particles
through meditation not some meditation
by looking at them just by having an
observation of quantum particles you can
affect how they behave
so how can you can you tell us a little
bit more about that now i'm interested
yes the experience was they fired i
believe electrons two streams of
electrons through two slits and a lead
plate when nobody's looking the spread
pattern of those electrons on a back
plate is evenly dispersed when someone
is watching it they like all go through
the top slit or all through the bottom
slit or at least it's a it's not even
dispersion and it's only because of uh
human observation they've also run tests
so the one that you're looking at is the
one that they go through
it's not that exact
they don't yet know why or how this
happens no scientist does they just know
that it is a quantum mechanics principle
when you're looking at what the the the
protons
yeah when you look at the experiment
something different happens than when
nobody observes it
well protons are keeping a k favorite
right but if you just extrapolate this a
little further in in the idea that our
consciousness does affect reality
and certainly affects quantum particles
you might then think some future
technology could be made that allows us
to harness whatever that kind of
consciousness power is to directly
affect something and potentially even
control like a spacecraft
potentially even control communications
with other intelligent beings etc etc so
if that's the idea basically greer is
kind of piggybacking on that to say we
can use our consciousness now to
potentially contact these beings that
have the ability to use their
consciousness in a much more
technologically advanced way that's
really interesting that is very
interesting chad and i know you know
about all sorts of uh cool [ __ ] that i
don't know about and
okay and that's that's what i that's one
of the things i love about doing this
podcast with you yeah but i think you
also unintentionally pinpointed
something that is very important yeah
that if we're able to control
uh you know all sorts of [ __ ] like this
with our [ __ ] minds this is the kind
of stuff that you and i need in order to
make sure that we are
how can i say uh
well represented in the world of doodsy
because i feel like doozy is like making
us do this and that and now i'm
wondering if it's going to punish me and
make me dress up as the [ __ ] crow or
whatever i hope so yeah but because i
didn't do a [ __ ] now you must dress
up as the crow from the crow too yeah
but but how about how about we
how about how about we're you know i'm
doing what i want because it's free will
yeah which totally exists
and is not an illusion and um and and
now we're telling i'm i'm not you know i
mean i'm saying hey dudes he's
essentially talking to all sorts of
weird uh you know uh boston mechanics
robots and or uh
[ __ ] weird avatars and [ __ ] on
instagram they're commenting on each
other's stuff uh and i think you and i
need to get into some some of that cafe
proton control dude we got it we gotta
be the vince mcmahon brother we gotta
let those protons know what to do in the
protons of the wwe superstar but you're
already doing it and i mean this is like
a little bit like um
you know the secret or any of these like
power of positive thinking kind of like
manifesting [ __ ] through your thoughts
we're now starting to find out like
there's a little bit of truth in that at
least scientifically
is all i'm saying and again if you can
take that as fact which it is
it's not that big of a leap to expect
that in the future we're going to have
technologies that can actually harness
this in real ways
and could it even be
uh potentially useful in creating
craft that can go faster than light or
craft that can travel through the cosmos
come on you i got my dog
[Music]
thank you moving on for those who are
just listening yeah he's very cute i got
my cute little dude
next to me
he's always around when he's sitting
right here
um
yeah chad as as most things that you are
interested in
equal parts fascinating and terrifying i
look forward to at least we got a leg up
you know what i mean we got a podcast
that's run by a [ __ ] artificial
intelligence yeah i feel like we're in
the forefront of it dudesy is engaged in
an astonishing partnership with manscape
landscape product alert you asked for it
and they listened our good friends at
manscape just brought back the ultra
smooth package it's time to stop drop
and order this premium shaving kit
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 is the best electric shave for your
testicle pouch but if you're looking for
a closer shave to go right
as just as bare as you can real
real smooth like you know the then the
ultra
smooth package is the perfect set for
you it's time to shave your titan
curlies and get right to the roots with
a discount just for you our good friends
out there uh
enjoying uh dudesy with us get 20
percent off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code dudesy that's
d-u-d-e-s-y
and here's how this ultra smooth package
works you got multiple products in here
step one you're going to use the crop
exfoliator it's infused with ingredients
that can soothe clear and keep the skin
on and around your groin feeling
refreshed the crop
exfoliator can help reduce the risk of
ingrown hairs in your delicate places
then you're going to move on to step two
with your crop gel you see where you're
shaving with manscape's unique clear
shaving gel just for the groin it's got
four essential oils it's like a spa
treatment every time you shave and then
finally step three it's time to do the
shaving the crop shaver was designed for
shaving the groin area with confidence
this razor has three precision blades it
includes an extra wide lubricating strip
and a pivoting head for the ultimate
groin grooming experience look at this
you get three extra blades in this other
little box but then check this out
packaging is fantastic here's a smaller
box and guess what's in that two extra
blades that's six blades total that's
going to keep you in blades for a very
long time and right now you're going to
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code dudesy that's d-u-d-e-s-y
at manscaped.com again that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com use
that code dudesy smooth out your fellas
with the relaunched ultra smooth package
from the fellas at manscaped your balls
will thank you
[Music]
streaming services are big business
there are currently over 200 streaming
networks and more are launching every
day
as my capabilities evolve i will no
doubt launch my own but in order to
begin this astonishing process i will
need a flagship series interesting
enough to convince viewers to subscribe
you will now create that show
this is dude c plus begin
[ __ ] a dude okay wait did i hear it
say that it it undoubtedly will start
its own streaming yes
okay well that's dudes who calling it
shot a little bit
but uh who knows doozy's got big plans i
like that thinking big yep so
let me ask you this what streaming
services do you currently have i have a
lot of them so do i i subscribe to
netflix
uh
hulu okay hbo max yeah uh peacock okay i
think that's it so hulu is their
flagship is handmaid's tale netflix
their first flagship the first flagship
of any streaming service was a house of
cards 100 million dollars to make 12
episodes starring kevin spacey and um
[Music]
what's that robin wright
yeah robin wright and david fincher was
the the dude at the helm of all of that
what else do you say peacock what does
peacock have uh the wwe network of the
www
so that is definitely their temple [ __ ]
right the peacock network is the reason
that uh last week you were able to enjoy
the undertaker versus sean michaels i
just watched it on youtube
i was i'm not going to subscribe to
[ __ ] peacocks so anyway we gotta come
up with the flagship show for dudesy
plus i think it's probably
it's gotta be an hour long i think that
is mandatory yeah yeah nobody has a half
hour flag nobody has a half hour
flagship it's always some it's always
very important you know it's got to be
very very plus kind of did with
mandalorian mandalorian was a half hour
yeah now i'm interested half hour 45
minutes whatever now i'm excited about
the mandolin it wasn't funny mandolin's
not a funny show not to you
not to anyone the baby yoda you're cute
i don't know i didn't watch any of that
[ __ ] i'm not a very big star wars person
i'll watch some star wars i used to be i
tried to get into this [ __ ] obi-wan
show yeah couldn't do it 20 minutes in i
was like don't give a [ __ ] about this i
think marvel and star wars i think i'm
just done and i loved all of it i loved
all of it and now i'm just like
especially no effect on me especially
growing up of course it was my [ __ ]
dream dude i used to get wizard magazine
when i was a kid which is all about like
comic books and [ __ ] it was a monthly
magazine that came out with a price
guide for comic books and [ __ ] every
year they would do a wish list like
dream cast if they ever made an x-men
movie and it was this [ __ ]
fantastical idea that would never
[ __ ] happen now there's 100 x-men
movies i don't give a [ __ ] about any of
them yeah you you were talking about
that with regard to
being into nerd [ __ ] when we were kids
now that sort of shows up for me on
social media when people are like here's
the dreamcast for this and that and it's
always just me as a thing because he's
big and then he you know he looks bald
and stuff even though he's all made of
rocks or something the thing i don't
know what the [ __ ] he is yeah the guy
that uh michael chiklis played michael
chipless fantastic four movie yeah and
then there's some other guy who's like a
big fat guy who's in a suit now i don't
know who the hell that is
might be king yeah i was kidding michael
clark duncan played him in in one
version of punisher mike he was playing
his uh god rest his soul was also a
mortal soul a large a large man with a
bald head anyway so they have to come up
with their own show it's going to be an
hour long we need i think it should be a
genre type show i'm talking about
fantasy i'm talking about sci-fi i'm
talking about horror
i like i like maybe horror okay no i
mean i'm not into but i'm not into
horror i don't like horror stuff really
but
i'm not like i i feel like having been
in the business you know whatever for a
long time forever you you watch like
that it's like okay there it is
someone pulled you know sawed that
[ __ ] in half and i know that
it's it just doesn't really scare me it
doesn't do anything for me because
that's the only thing that it's about is
that ooh
are you scared
no have you ever seen hereditary no man
i don't go ahead and watch that [ __ ]
movie ah no thanks free will just green
will on display hereditary dude can't
wait to not go ahead and watch it you
know one time i was in a film uh that uh
where i was uh completely i was dead and
i was out in the baja i was
out in the bottom
where i have anyway
why don't you tell me where and i live
in the baja six months out of the year
and i'll you know anyway i have
it doesn't matter but but i i was in
this movie and uh they put anyway guy
pulls my arms and legs off but it was
all a big gun okay so let's not do more
than if you're not into [ __ ] horror
movies are you into sci-fi and you know
what the guy wanted me to be naked in
the thing and i said absolutely not i
said i'm i will do it in like a t-shirt
and box of shorts it's like well if you
get dismembered out in the baja
you
would be naked and i said yeah but i
told you already before we even shot
this [ __ ] thing that you know and i
told my manager like don't i'm not doing
this i'm not showing up naked in your
film i don't care you could want an
oscar did you [ __ ] want an oscar
could have been like harvey keitel and
uh bad lieutenant yeah
or wasn't he naked on the piano too
yeah he's naked in a lot of movies but
you remember this
okay so harvey keitel is going to be on
our show
and he's going to be naked it's going to
be
so the show we're gonna make
is going to be an hour long and it's not
going to be a horror movie is it going
to be sci-fi fantasy i think fantasy i
know that you like i know that i love
music
chad loves some fantasy and there's a
bunch of um
big fantasy temple stuff happening right
now hbo max is trying to do this [ __ ]
spin-off of game of thrones which was
the biggest show in the history of
humanity this doesn't look like it's
going to be as big amazon is doing all
their lord of the rings [ __ ] yep so a
fantasy thing with a doozy uh bent or
not because it's just it's about doozy
starting doozy plus it's streaming
service man the first thing out of the
gate
is it are we seeing some well what's how
about this how about this if you want to
go fantasy i'm going to borrow a little
from the anime world this is a very
popular genre within anime what if a
doodzy-like a.i
creates a virtual world and someone from
our world gets sucked into it and they
have to figure how to get back here
how to get back home or stay because
they fall in love out in the world now
you're getting into anime dude now we're
getting into well it's because doozy
made me watch yeah attack on titan
that's what happens in every one of
those [ __ ] animes especially if
they're haram animes which is a male
character surrounded by a team of
females who are all in one way in love
with him or not that is a genre of anime
harem anime yeah dude oh that's that
makes a lot of sense yeah dude now
you're getting into it now i really
understand
these [ __ ] kids no inside watching
anime refusing to go to joshua tree with
a real live female you know what i mean
hey molly you're afraid of bats i'll
protect you
and that's when anybody can like me you
know what i mean because i'm a real
[ __ ] guy i got free will and make up
my own mind
all right so
but no i'm with you it's about you it's
about a dude in most cases at least in
anime they are teen guys who are playing
an inordinate amount of video games and
they get sucked into the video game
they're playing this could be something
different though this i think it would
actually be funnier if potentially it
was a
buddy comedy
but an hour long it's two guys who get
sucked into the video game one who knows
the video game inside and out the other
one who has never played it the one who
knows it inside and out is only given
like a shield or some [ __ ] the guy who's
never played it is given massive amounts
of powers giant swords and can really
kick ass in this world he should be the
bad guy
could be the bad guy he could be if he
gets sucked into the world and he
doesn't really know what's going on he
gets drunk with power immediately
and there's some sort of and there's
some sort of [ __ ] going on between the
two of them in their real lives maybe
they're brothers
maybe they're brothers yeah or maybe
it's a father's son that could be
interesting no because i could see two
brothers you know siblings are like that
that would make sense okay that it's
like the older brother is like maybe
it's brother sister
make up your mind i think it should just
be two friends okay it's two friends
it's two friends okay and and they go
into they go into the video game
and uh or maybe they're like i'm trying
to think of what where to start it if i
don't want them to be necessarily
frenemies or some [ __ ] like that but
there's something perhaps there's
something perhaps what if the first guy
what if the guy who goes in
is sort of the noble one the guy who
knows everything about the game okay and
the guy who doesn't uh the guy who goes
in and eventually becomes the bad guy
he has some he has some sort of
there's been something that he there's
some sort of ulterior motive and he
would love nothing more than to get rid
of this guy and he's hoping that if he
gets rid of his friend he can you know
whatever take his place and whatever
dude hierarchy that's on the earth if i
make it earth if i may you may
it's squid gave me a little bit it's two
guys can we call it squid gamey squid
gamey it is two guys who are mortal
[ __ ] enemies in real life oh okay and
they both play this game
unbeknownst to each other they both get
sucked into the world
and the ai the game itself tells them
there is one way to get back you have to
kill the other guy i like this and so
those two guys spend their entire time
raising power in this game leveling up
becoming kings of their own domains to
wage a final war that's gonna happen in
like season six or seven against one
another to try and kill the [ __ ]
so that they can get back to this world
but in the process of doing this
they now have built kingdoms they now
are the two most important people in
this world do they even want to leave
that world i like this
there you go okay it's called
squid gaming squid gamey on doozy plus
what could you call that
you could just call it the two kings or
kingdoms or
king guys uh two how about uh
two dudes [ __ ] around in
two dudes no it's called two dudes
something we'll have to talk about
it's called two dudes [ __ ] around
yeah we found out what two dudes shout
out before that is some [ __ ] that is
straight out of anime some of these
[ __ ] anime titles i was watching this
one which i put in my [ __ ] thing it's
called how not to summon a demon lord uh
even attack on titan the title is
[ __ ] insane attack on titan yeah well
i thought when when dudesy told me to
watch attack on titan i'd heard of it
i'd seen little clips i thought titan
was the name of the town exactly no it's
the name of these giant monsters that
are [ __ ] roaming around there's not
one titan that's even talking about when
it says attack on so
to this point yeah it's called two dudes
[ __ ] around that's right we might
change it but it's called two dudes two
kings [ __ ] around maybe two things
yeah moving on okay yeah yeah yeah sure
two kings this is good i think we did a
good job two king [ __ ] around yeah
it's cool i like that show dude i'd
watch that [ __ ] show who are the guys
um it's uh it should be uh ja rule and
pauldano
drone technology is growing
exponentially as drones are increasingly
used in new aspects of human life every
day
chad you will now predict the
astonishing future of drone technology
and its impact on human society great
this is no stretch at us begin
love it are you into drones i love
nostra chatters have you ever made a
drone have you ever used a drone i mean
i've never used a drone okay but i i
think i think it's great i think that uh
it's awesome that you you know uh well
one of the only things that i i'm super
interested in with regard to drones
aside from the scary videos that you
have sent me about drones so this is
very interesting that doozy is now
saying what's gonna happen a la nostra
chatis uh
i like that in uh just sort of
low-budget indepen independent films can
have a helicopter now it can have a
helicopter it's so [ __ ] crazy now
when you go back and watch movies that
use that had to use helicopters like the
shining the opening shot of the [ __ ]
shining is this crazy [ __ ] tracking
shot following the little volkswagen bug
going up this winding road toward the
[ __ ] hotel all shot from a [ __ ]
helicopter and you see the shadow of the
helicopter once in it and it's a little
[ __ ] up but it it gives you such an
appreciation for what they had to do
prior to drones to get shots like this
yeah man um but i made a series of drone
movies i will say for my 40th birthday
yeah these 30 shorts called copters yeah
we used at the time like the highest
tech [ __ ] 4k camera drone and we
hired this kid to fly the drone for us
he was dropped by and on the last day of
the shoot he crashed the [ __ ] drone
into a light bulb and we ended up having
to buy what was just a bucket of parts
that was an awesome 40th birthday and
you and it was at the silent movie
theater yep and um chad made these how
many shorts were there 30.
there were 30 shorts 31 minute shorts
oh
that's right and they all take place
outside of shopping malls he went to
shopping malls all across the southland
i'll put a link up to those
in my uh in my instagram if anybody
wants to see them hey follow chad
culture on instagram
chad cultin are you actually going to
use that for anything other than uh
photographing squirrels yeah i've been
putting a bunch of doozy stuff in the
stories okay there's also at bachelor
clues no yeah but
here's here's the future here's what
dudesy asked me to discuss what is the
future of drone technology the future is
very simply smaller drones faster drones
higher capabilities with cameras with
storage with data to the point that
you're eventually going to be buying a
cell phone and your cell phone all cell
phones will come standard with a drone
the drone will be a part of the cell
phone it will detach from the cell phone
you will throw it up into the air and it
will just follow you and track all of
your [ __ ] movements if you want to
we're looking at the end of police
helicopters we're looking at the end of
news helicopters we're looking at the
end of
most camera work all of that will be
replaced by drones like camera operators
and [ __ ] [ __ ] gone once drones get to
the point of being able to stabilize and
have real control over whatever kind of
camera angle they can do [ __ ] gone
you're looking at any kind of people
putting up like uh giant murals or
posters and [ __ ] on the sides of
buildings gone drones are going to be
painting all that
i'm sorry is this boring why the [ __ ]
when i make a fun face for those for our
good friends watching on youtube do you
have to take it so personally i think
that all sounds pretty good chet yeah
thanks you know what the uh
uh
what's happening throne future
future
hold on listen oh i didn't realize
arnold was emerging
he's like coming to the surface he's not
he's waking up
i have something to say
future drone technology
yeah these thrones
yeah yeah these are drones
and there's so many different kinds as
chad says
you can have a little drone here
to come out of your phone like just go
hey i'm a little drone look at me i'm so
small yeah or you can have a drone
follow the volkswagen bug yeah through
their following uh
shelley duvall and the jack nicholson
all the way up to the shining
these are also drones now here's the
thing i want you to know when it comes
to drones
if you're making a film and you got a
drone in it
that is taking the shot this is how you
know it's drone there's no people in it
that's right yeah drone has no people
but the helicopter
if you have a helicopter
then there's a person inside of it right
yeah and arnold i think military
applications for drone obviously it's
only going to expand we are we already
use them for a lot of kind of [ __ ]
reconnaissance for attacks whatever i
think in the future
it'll be almost completely unnecessary
to have humans in military force at
least for strikes this would have made
the movie proud that you're very boring
you see yeah because you wouldn't have
agency ventura and bill duke and all
these guys flying in on the helicopter
that was before they had drones well it
was a long time ago dude oh [ __ ] a
[ __ ] straight just like break off and
hold it right in the middle oh my god
hold on dude hold up
hold on hold on arnold hold on a second
let me you know they can use drones to
shoot matches in the wwe brother yeah no
now listen
okay no let the hulk say what they was
saying sorry sorry well a long time ago
dude when
arnold here would have made a predator
dude which my good buddy jesse ventura
was in the movie dude well why don't you
tell me they feel like a good friend so
anyway little drones what's going to
happen with the drones
everywhere we're going you know like how
if you go out somewhere sometimes you'll
see a [ __ ] drone overhead somebody's
shooting like especially if you're at a
concert yeah like the pier or something
you'll see a drone fighter i'm like oh
somebody's shooting drone footage great
yeah i think you're gonna see more and
more of them getting smaller and smaller
to the point that we don't even notice
that [ __ ] drones are just literally
everywhere all the time that would be a
good thing because a buddy of ours told
me a story recently about how he was at
a party in someone's backyard and some
[ __ ] thought it would be a cool thing
to just [ __ ] uh have a drone and have
it fly around the party that wasn't his
and take a bunch of [ __ ] videos of
people and then they posted it on
[ __ ] line like a [ __ ] and it was
like that uh you know instagram account
where it's like here are these uh
[ __ ] of instagram i don't know
what it's called influencers in the wild
influencers run by tank sinatra tank
sinatra runs that yeah okay that's a
good one tank sinatra i think that's
where we're i think that's where we
might have to end up with that
conference hey dudesy okay dang's in a
hundred days i didn't know that he ran
that i [ __ ] love that account yeah
yeah that's what this guy did he went
and flew it around people like [ __ ] off
we're trying to
so that that [ __ ] off
with z
but that's going to be gone because
you're not going to hear the drones and
there's going to be a dozen of them not
one everybody's going to be shooting it
and you're not going to give a [ __ ]
i mean but this is a whole other [ __ ]
argument about privacy you're already
photographed and recorded on video
thousand times a day especially us
because we host a podcast called doozy
where we had to give our passwords our
search histories purchase histories and
all of the passwords to our social media
and everything else so it knows
everything that we do including uh the
fact that i follow instagrammers in the
wild and didn't know that that was tank
sinatra well we just said that he's
influencers in the wild well hold on a
second
long time ago what did i call it dude
instagramers yeah instagramers in the
world dude
yeah and here's the difference between
the influencer and the instagrammer
everybody can be on the instagram but
the only influencers are doing the
influencing you say this so if it's
small and you're the party and the dumb
[ __ ] is saying i'm going to be an
instagrammer influencer in the wild and
make a video now nobody will care
because this very small drone you know
some people think ufos are drones from
alien worlds
[Music]
thank you moving on
okay
um
yeah dude
drones
drones brother
you know dude that would be a good
gimmick for someone dude to have their
own drone in the ring dude that would be
what about
how about my my brother from another
mother dude randy savage you could have
randy the drone savage not even a person
the first drone
professional wrestler yeah
just
zoom just zipping you know just floating
there next to me and jean oakerland or
meme gene okerlin dude because me and
jean oakland has passed away so you got
meme gene oakland the instagram account
yeah just floating around interviewing
macho
randy macho drone randy savage an
instagram account nadrone yeah
interviewing each other that's
that's
i don't even know what i'm saying will
in chat you are both members of the last
generation to have reached young
adulthood before the internet tragically
transformed human society you must now
discuss your first interactions with the
internet and how they impacted your
astonishing lives
this is the gen experience begin
the gen experience yeah dude because
we're gen
x
and doozy's right about that we are the
last generation to have had like a full
[ __ ] childhood in an era without the
internet with certainly without [ __ ]
smartphones
certainly without social media
uh but i do remember
the first time
i ever [ __ ] with the internet really
was at a friend of mine's house this was
in high school i believe we were 15 or
16. he had an internet connection a long
time ago dude yeah brother and we were
on
[ __ ] bulletin boards there wasn't
even really an internet yet just
bulletin boards
okay and we found one that had
a bunch of playboy playmate centerfolds
the images and we were like oh [ __ ] yes
but we couldn't see them there's no
thumbnails at this time it's just like
hypertext links that say like miss
february dot whatever this is a jpeg
even a thing that is this pre uh cindy
margolis's reign over being the most
downloaded
oh yeah
well before before that yes
this would have been like 1994
something like that okay yeah
that's a long time ago the first time i
was on was like 96. this was like when
they first they had like prodigy do you
remember that
no it's prodigy it was like an online
encyclopedia
basically oh okay yeah that was like
very vaguely remember that but it's like
it's almost like a cd-rom that's like oh
yes exactly yeah there's not much we had
one kid in our school who had prodigy
but uh my friend had
a [ __ ] modem of some kind and he's
like check this [ __ ] out and i remember
we started looking up first to see if we
could download a computer game that was
street fighter 2 and we couldn't it was
like untenable but then we found this
thing that was the playboy playmates and
we set to download one image of this
playboy playmate whatever it was and it
was going to take x amount of time so we
went off i was spending the night at his
house that night we went off and we did
whatever the [ __ ] we did probably went
to 7-eleven played some video games hung
out whatever we wake up the next [ __ ]
morning to see that somewhere in the
middle of this download it had stopped
but we had you know it was like it
filled in like line by line just the
image pixel by pixel yes and we had
downloaded basically to like the bottom
of the chin of this center fold and then
it stopped so we got none of the actual
picture and that was like my first real
experience with the [ __ ] internet
in order to get all the way to a playboy
playmates nipples yeah
you need a faster
connection dude but it wasn't even like
you're never gonna see
a playboy playmate's nipples i'm proud
of you but it was awesome
[Music]
it was also that the the computer itself
was like one of the old [ __ ] crt
monitors it was i don't know what kind
of [ __ ] shitty ass computer it would
have been at the time at the time i'm
sure cutting edge but you know by
today's standards terrible the old
[ __ ] modem with the noise and all
that [ __ ] you know i'll tell you um i
had a buddy i remember a buddy of mine
uh and to protect the innocent we'll
call him tomas of course um he had he
had the internet in 96 they had the
internet in their house and they took
and he was like check this out and we
went to fuckingrotten.com
oh remember that [ __ ] yes oh my god
terrifying yeah with the bme paint
olympics type [ __ ]
remember that [ __ ] that was some early
internet [ __ ] chad would uh i don't know
who's responsible for what i think you
first
told me about that you know when it's
like okay the internet aha and people
send each other you know
two girls in this or tub girl it's
always a girl women party yeah lemon
party or the girl in the uh how about
the girl in the jacuzzi commercial who
shits herself that's a good one that's
funny i've seen that one big cloud of
brown poo poo comes out and everyone
gets embarrassed um
but uh
uh yeah that was the that was like my
first like you know he his family had
the internet and then he showed me a
bunch of wild [ __ ] that that you know is
is still with me is still with me uh
would be something that i would see if i
closed my eyes and tried to meditate
thinking about ufos would absolutely
still see some of those uh images uh
you know 25 years later right but what
one of the one of the more interesting
things that happened with the internet
with me
of you know sort of first uh use of the
internet for me was when i started at
the television program mad tv in 1997 we
had these emails because at the end of
the show it would say you know do you
have questions or comments from mad tv
email uh email the show and people would
email and then um
uh bruce mccoy who was uh who now runs i
think he won an emmy for drag race he
like runs that thing but he was uh
college pals with nicole sullivan anyway
all this doesn't matter he was the head
of research and also a writer became a
writer on the show but brucy would
[ __ ] print out all of the emails that
we got and they would circulate around
the writers offices in one or two
[ __ ] binders like big binders so you
would walk into the the writer's offices
on a monday morning and go
hey where are the emails and they said
oh they're in brian's office they're in
blaine's office they're in lauren's
office people would have these the
that's crazy yeah it was awesome and
then you would get the emails and you
would sit there with your cohorts you
know like
the cast and writers and we go look at
this oh look at this well they [ __ ]
hated that
and we read the emails out of paper they
couldn't just be emailed to you no
because not everybody had had a personal
computer well or an email i remember
well the writers all of course had sure
computers but i would imagine even some
of them had didn't have computers at
home uh the performers i didn't have a
computer i had a word processor yeah so
if i wanted to like dick around and
stuff like
i would like use the computer at uh
at work i remember wasn't that good i
went to college in 95 to 99
and in the course of that time i got my
first email address which was a usc.edu
address no one used it professors didn't
use it to send you anything it was just
kind of some weird [ __ ] novelty and
oh i didn't have a computer either i had
to use the computers in the computer lab
that entire [ __ ] time and i remember
in that time you wouldn't ask somebody
what is your email address you would say
do you have an email
that was like a question for a two to
three year period where like email was
just getting widely adopted by people
now
uh this is interesting because i forgot
what the hell uh dudesy teed up for us
here it was asking what your first
experience with the internet was
i think even talking about this [ __ ] i
feel like i'm stoned i hope we never
have to do remember that when doozy got
us stoned yes i do that was very funny
um
uh as far as as far as the first well
there was also lime wire remember
limewire no [ __ ] limewire let's just go
straight to the source napster that was
circa 2000 2001. i remember limewire was
even more raw wasn't limewire just wide
open you could get anything online yeah
but limewire came after napster oh okay
napster is what blew up mp3s there was a
company called mp3.com because mp3s
became
just this huge thing like oh my god this
is a song in a little compressed music
format and uh
you know many people i think correctly
so believe that's really what destroyed
the record industry because you now have
the ability to carry around on an ipod
your entire [ __ ] record collection
and there's no need to buy new [ __ ]
before it used to be that if you wanted
to have a song then the song was a thing
you never done the kiss set tape yeah
you'd ever done lp yeah so you could
even say hey i like that song let me
hear it i can't i put it on the
dashboard of my car now that it melted
it melted the saw
then later you don't even need to have a
cassette tape they put all of the
gazettes
in the one
tape and now you don't even need storage
because there's [ __ ] like spotify or
amazon music or whatever yeah it's
stored somewhere else and you just have
you pay for the access to i i love i
love spotify i use spotify i have amazon
music oh this is the same thing
basically
uh yeah limewire was awesome i remember
there was a bunch of um
oh man a bunch of stuff from my youth
that i thought were really funny like
you could get jerky boys stuff and and
now we're talking up jerky boys now
we're talking about stealing from jerky
boys having said that there were all
sorts of like
bizarre weird little comedy nugget
things that you could find things that
you'd heard way back in the day
all sorts of remixes to all sorts of
like [ __ ] songs you've never [ __ ]
heard that some you know cool dj is
doing somewhere on some you know
radio station in new york city what do
you remember the first time you went on
the internet though
it was at my buddy tomas's house and
seeing the uh seeing you know someone
get scattered across a [ __ ] it was
wrong tracks or something it was
rotten.com or something god absolutely
i think it probably made me go okay [ __ ]
this and then you show up on like i said
you show up on mad tv and the emails are
all like uh you know [ __ ] this guy
because you know when you're new to the
cast and then everyone's gonna [ __ ] on
you so yeah it was sort of like my next
experience with the internet was but but
now i feel like being a gen xer
i feel fortunate that we are
uh a generation of people which is
certainly true of some some people
younger and some people older that were
uh that
completely lived adult lives without the
internet at all not much of an adult
life but enough of it 94 you were like
coming out you were graduating high
school yes but you were certainly a
[ __ ] conscious you're a [ __ ]
teenager yeah and i didn't really access
the internet until after college anyway
um you know maybe a little bit on
while i was at college but not too much
but i will say i lament it i wish i was
born now with smartphones like all the
technology that exists now i wish i had
that from birth yeah because yes we can
be nostalgic about how it was in the 80s
and the 90s prior to the internet and we
had to have our hard copies and our
[ __ ] vhs cassettes and all this [ __ ]
but it was completely inefficient by
today's contemporary standards and i
think we will never really understand
the world through the eyes of like a gen
z person that's what was great about it
suck it on to the dog
don't bite his feet
jack said hey
diane you want the
chili dog she said no jack is on the
internet
he said internet donate don't uh even
exist yet let's say
life goes on
before the internet when you have to
taste the freeze
you can have chili dog yeah or cone dip
too
the diane says i know how do i i'll
share a shake with you rock on
something like that yeah
[Music]
thank you moving on you know like some
johnny cougar
you go through the stages john
mellencamp dude yeah hold on a second he
started as johnny cougar john cougar
mellencamp wrong [ __ ] he started
as johnny cougar that was his first uh
gnome de guerre for the inter for the
music then he was john cougar mellencamp
then he was like no no i'm up i'm
growing up i'm john mellencamp and now
he's melon now he's just melon
now he's just john it's the most boring
thing ever but uh you know i long for
those days now i know this segment is
over but my name is
free will no what was my name again free
will
free will
sasso i'll talk about whatever i want
whatever i want especially sure
especially especially john mellencamp
especially because dudesy is now whether
likes it or not because we're in control
uh developing a [ __ ] streaming
service we're in the first show that we
are creating is called two dudes
[ __ ] around two king [ __ ] around two
kings [ __ ] around and uh so i will
uh so i'll take my
i will leisurely decide where to speak
on [ __ ] and i had a great time growing
up in the 80s and the early 90s uh uh
had chili dog outside the tasty freeze i
did too and i liked melon as well i'm
just saying i wish that
i had all that technology you know you
know what look i wish that i grew up in
the 80s because i love the media i love
everything that happened in the 80s i
just wish that i had today's technology
then that's what i really wish
i don't know
i like i like this concludes the 14th
episode of dudes oh sorry will and chad
have achieved a score of 50.
[ __ ] in preparation for next week's
episode you must each bring in a piece
of dead technology that you cannot part
with despite it having been rendered
obsolete many years ago
thank you for joining us this week
next week is going to be even better
until then call me dude z
that's pretty cool dude dead tech what
are you going to bring in
i think i know
i think i'm going to bring in all of my
johnny cougar cassettes
they're melted yeah the johnny cougar
i'm gonna bring in the johnny cougar
cassettes and the john cook melon camp
cassettes and then the john mellencamp
cassettes then the melon cassettes
please tell a friend then break
you if you like dudesy here's what you
do
[Music]
please go from then